baby if you give it to me i give it to
you
i know what you want you know so
my singing right there
you are music royalty you have your pick
of
anything under the sun that you want to
do what makes you say
yes i gotta do the mass singer i think
everybody knows that i'm always about to
feel good energy and i'm always about
the
the having fun and turning up and i
think that it's important to still
you know remind people that we gotta
live and we need to
laugh and we need to love them while
we're learning as much as we
you know us black and brown people and
particularly in these times have to
focus on and fight for
and stand firm on our square and really
represent ourselves in a new way that
shows
you know tremendous amount of strength
and resistance
and endurance and sacrifice i think that
sometimes in order to continue to
to fight these battles and these
challenges that we're facing
in in extreme fashions in the current
time space
you know we need moments to be able to
refuel and recharge
and i think that you know being able to
remember that we got to live a little
bit
and have some fun and being able to
loosen up is a part of that
it was just a wonderful opportunity and
besides i'm a fan of the show my kids is
a fan of the show
a lot of my homies mom rap peers we love
the show we talk about the show
you know what i'm saying it's each other
you're one of us i'm definitely
all the way one of us and one of you
you're one of us too
this show of course is shrouded in
secrecy i gotta know real quick
who knew that you were doing this show
outside of my immediate team
nobody so what would you say when
friends
fellow rap stars when people would hit
you up what would you say
i didn't say nothing you know it's
really not that hard to
mind your own business and to also value
your privacy i come from that time
yes and i come from the town where the
civil liberty of privacy was very
valuable
all of these camera phones and big
brother wasn't implemented in the way
that it is now
look i remember in the 90s i had my
landline and i was calling trl
saying i want what's it going to be at
the top of the chart
obviously here we are you know 20 some
odd years later baby just tell me just
how you feel
[Music]
after the big reveal last night who of
your celebrity friends
either tweeted you or texted you to be
like dude i knew it was you like who hit
you up to tell you that they enjoyed
watching you
it was a few the one that i spoke to
several times that was real enthusiastic
for me was my brother swiss beast
he's a huge fan of the show what'd he
say he just thought it was an incredible
look for me
and it was it was dope and he thought it
was fun and he thought that you know i
did well but
you know he always is an advocate for me
to always remind people
of you know what busta rhymes is
and what boston rhymes will always be
and that is one of the most important
things that
you got people around you that do that
because sometimes you know especially
with this this last hiatus that i've
taken you know my last album came out in
2009
i don't completely go away you know
y'all got look at me now with me and
chris brown
i put out the year the dragon project
for free when the google play platform
was being launched
you're a showman through and through
yeah yeah through and you just you bring
so much i mean i said it before but
you're just electrifying truly you
always have been you've always been in a
true lane
of your own and i have to tell you look
you kind of mentioned you know off
projects that you did here and there
one of the anthems is don'tcha by the
pussycat dolls
and of course this show marked somewhat
of a reunion between you and nicole
scherzinger
once you were revealed did you guys
reminisce about
that moment in time or maybe
collaborating again in the future
now we actually didn't talk about none
of that we just talked about keeping in
touch because we have a
beautiful friendship and same with robin
thicke that's my brother same with
cannon that's my brother she hit me
after
and just was like it was so good to see
you you know what i'm saying
we i miss you i hope all is well with
you and your family
you know let's keep in touch because we
shouldn't let so much time pass
before 15 years yeah we don't always
speak on the phone as frequently as we
should and all of the trying times
happening right now
we just all are making it a point to
value time a little differently
[Music]
of course we saw you do mama said knock
you out of course an iconic rap song
you're known to be an iconic rapper but
this is a singing competition if you had
gone
further do you think you would have
performed songs
um that involve or require singing like
did you have some songs picked out for
the next
couple episodes yeah i definitely would
have done some song singing because you
know there's
artists that sing that i know the songs
of well and that
not only was i raged on but you know
those songs kind of even inspired
you know what i do creatively with my
own music can you share one
no don't don't you ask me to give away
none of my secret weapons
especially if they have i i think it
would just be such a treat for fans to
hear you sing a little since we were
robbed of that
opportunity on the show maybe if you
give it to me
i give it to you i know what you want
you know so my singing right there
iconic as you mentioned 11 years since
your last album came out we're so
excited about the new music
you know the thing about you is that
you're you're just a master of your
craft
and this is a very basic question but i
think a lot of people are curious
how the heck do you rap so fast what is
it that you do to process
the brain with the mouth that makes it
come out like just
perfection i'm feeling like i gotta get
away get away get away
years of practice understanding the
science of breath control
and relaxing when you're actually speed
rapping
i think you know people are used to
seeing me so animated and
i exuberate so much energy when i'm
actually performing my regular records
but if you do the research and you pay
attention like if you go and google any
of my shows or youtube some of my shows
you'll notice as much as i might act
crazy when i'm doing scenario
when i do like a look at me now verse i
actually stand still in one place
because the precision and the focus on
the precision of how i articulate
the breath control has a lot to do with
that so if i'm not breathing right
i won't deliver it right so that's kind
of like a lot of what it has to do with
just knowing how to control your energy
and reserve your energy so that you can
be at your best
for the different songs that you're
doing for you as an entertainer
someone who's used to entertaining
hundreds of thousands of people on stage
what was it like performing to a crowd
of nobody
it's definitely not the same the beauty
about performing live
is the chemistry in the energy that's
unexplainable you can't really put a
direct description to it it almost is
like
it's a thing that's greater than man
that connection that you make
what do you do when you don't have that
in these coveted 19 times
if you love what you do and you still
got a passion and that fire still burns
internally you're going to give people
you know the energy anyway but again you
know when you ask me what it's like
not having them around it's definitely
not the same you know that you still got
to do it for them
and you're still doing it for yourself
and as long as you love it
you're still going to do it the way you
should and that's what's important i'm
always do it as long as i love it and
i'm still a fan of it
right busta rhymes doesn't know how to
do it any other way than 100.
that's a fan got new music you're
considered an
icon you just did the math singer you
have a beautiful family
is there any time for romance yeah but
that's the one thing that i'ma always
keep private because i just feel like
there's certain things that
you know ain't really none of people's
business but i definitely am proud
and and i love my queen and that's all
you're gonna get as far as that is
concerning
okay you know i definitely feel like
it's important that
certain things are just kept you know
between you and
and the people that needs to be a part
of that space